hey so this is just gonna be a fun
little announcement video that would be
where I announce thanks just in case
you're too busy to reporter just don't
feel like watching the entire few
minutes of this video let me tell you
what I talk about great I had a live
show it was fun i have a new show coming
out that you guys helped me Nick but
keep watching to find out that is also i
have a new YouTube channel if you do
calm such other iJustine yay oh and the
last thing I have a new fun contest
coming they keep watching for that
number one I had a live show the other
day so those of you the tuned in leave
me a comment down below and let me know
that you were there some of you guys got
my phone number off of twitter I posted
it and I took a bunch of live calls and
those people who didn't get through left
me some amazing a voicemail let's listen
to a few this is not it going well your
four digit pin is fail okay bye you know
let me imagine please meet chicks hey
course I cannot see a quorum like just
use your number out like that's like
really crazy like you and I wouldn't do
that on my even faces I have a ball so
Jim and it's like a crate then how many
was Samson recons review it off now what
are you doing I'm with my friend he's a
DJ I'm sure some of you are wondering
well just seeing how old why watch your
live show where do I where do I see it
where do I see how do i watch how do i
see you at what time most of my shows
are pretty impromptu and the only way to
actually be sure that you'll be able to
catch one is to follow me on Twitter I
know I know you're so sick of hearing my
mom's on Twitter my grandmother's on
twitter you can be on twitter too ok ok
ok a number two I swear there's only
three things that I won't talk about so
here's number two drumroll please well
you guys remember that episode of help
me make a show yeah that's right not
really an episode it's just a video but
either way you guys remember that one
well I'm finally going to follow through
on the first show idea that you guys had
asked i J that
right IJ is short for iJustine but to
make this work I'm going to need you
guys to ask the questions and judging by
my email you guys have a lot of
questions a lot of you guys have the
same questions so feel free to go right
down there ooh comments in the comments
type your question and I'll sort through
all the questions and you guys can see
the other questions that people are
asking and they will be in the first
episode of ask IJ number three I have a
new YouTube channel subscribe to it
youtube.com slash other i Justine why do
I have this new channel let me tell you
because people complain a lot if I post
an unedited video a fun little vlog
little hey hi this is what I'm up to
people complain way away when we win so
I heard you I made another channel so
check that out youtube.com slash other
iJustine where i'll be posting unedited
footage some behind the scenes scenes
and whatever else i feel like that is
not appropriate to post here Wow well
that's it thanks for making it all the
way to this video I'm pretty impressed
that you made it all this way anyways
make sure you leave your comments down
below about the ask IJ so feel free to
ask me questions and i'll answer those
and the last thing that I said was also
going to talk about was a contest and
I'm gonna be having and I will be giving
you guys more information about that
this upcoming week as well I have to go
out this weekend to my surprises for you
guys um that'll be fun I'll be seeing
you guys later on the Internet don't
forget to follow me on Twitter make sure
you subscribe comment rate whatever all
that stuff everybody says that you gotta
do you gotta do what you gotta do it
anyway that's it that's all that's all
I've got oh one more thing links in the
side
ah